Hey, here's an interesting side story from
the Iowa caucus.
Pete Buddha judge is a gay man and this is
known to a lot of people and it is wholly
irrelevant to me in thinking about whether
I agree with P booted judges policies.
There is viral video that has been released
of a voter in a rural part of Iowa on Monday
night who, um, realized after submitting her
vote in the caucus for Pete Buddha judge that
he is a gay man and that he has a same sex
partner and starts asking to take her vote
back.
A precinct captain for Pete has a conversation
with her, the video going completely viral.
Take a look,
came over to saying that he has the same sex
partner.
Yes.
Are you kidding?
He's married to him.
I don't want anybody like that.
So can I have my car back and they slip, we
can go ask.
I never knew that.
The whole point of it is though.
He's a human being just like you and me.
And should it really matter.
That's what fully better reads.
Bye.
The Bible is raised and actually the precinct
captain does a pretty good job of dealing
with that talking point by saying, listen,
we, we weren't around when it was written
and we don't really know what the intention
was.
Uh, and uh, the conversation continues.
He does.
And he says that God doesn't choose a political
party because why does it say in the Bible
that a man should marry a woman?
Then I totally respect your viewpoint on this.
I so totally do.
But I think that we were not around, been
brought out before.
It's common knowledge.
I never heard that.
So
this is important.
Uh, the fact that this woman had never heard
that Pete is gay.
Is that a sign of progress?
What I mean by that is if sexual orientation
is not part of the discussion around a candidate
and it's not part of this woman's awareness,
you could say that that's progress in the
sense that it simply was not a big enough
deal among voters that sexual orientation
was playing a big role in figuring out who
you want to support.
Now the, the thing about it is this woman
is wearing Amy Klobuchar stickers.
She was probably there supporting Amy and
then went to Pete after the first round or
whatever the case may be.
It may not really be an indication that most
people aren't aware of mayor Pete being gay
or whatever.
I don't know how big of a sign of anything
it really is, but in my mind, if it becomes
a relevant what one sexual orientation is
in terms of whether someone would support
them, it feels as though it is a step forward
to some degree.
Here's a little bit more of the video.
We can talk to somebody you we need to talk
to them about that.
I don't know all the rules on this or not,
but I guess what I would like you to just
take deep inside and think like should it
matter if it's for women or if it's a man
or if they're heterosexual or homosexual.
If you believe in what they say.
That's my question.
It all just went right down.
The toilet is where it all just went.
You have a total right to your opinion and
I am not trying to tell you to think, but
we'll ask what they want us to do, but I just,
I just asked you to look inside your heart
because you sound like a Christian woman to
me.
I'm a Christian woman, so you must not believe
it.
Then if you think it's okay for somebody to
meet to a same sex, Nope.
I think we're just interpreting it different
and that's okay because everybody gets happy,
gets to have their own beliefs about what
I teach my son is that love is love and we're
all human.
Really
interesting stuff.
There were initially some allegations that
this was staged in some way.
There's no evidence of that whatsoever.
From what I've read, the voter did ultimately
get her card back and was able to switch her
vote to Elizabeth Warren for mayor Pete on
that second round, there's an interesting
sort of policy question here.
Is there any candidate that opposes same sex
marriage at this point?
And I'm not even talking about on the democratic
side, Trump even seems fine with same sex
marriage.
So you know, is is the problem supportive
same sex marriage?
Because the voter says, the Bible talks about
marriage between being between a man and a
woman.
Pete is married to a man and support same
sex marriage.
All the other candidates are heterosexual,
but they support same sex marriage.
Donald Trump has heterosexual but seems okay
with same sex marriage, at least to the extent
that he's not made it any kind of a problem.
Is the problem being gay in the eyes of this
voter or is it supporting same sex marriage?
I don't know.
And then of course, remember the Bible says
don't eat shellfish, don't wear mixed fabric
clothing.
I don't know how many candidates are abiding
by those either.
So very strange and sort of interesting video.
And I, my view on this is I don't care what
anyone's sexual orientation is.
I care about their political positions because
of that.
I'm not a mayor Pete guy, but what I'm curious
about is do we see it as a sign of progress
that mayor Pete sexual orientation is unknown
to a lot of people or do we see it as an uninformed
electorate?
I don't know.
I open it up to you